hi Guys hi Guys hi guys I'm great I'm
not Greg this is Anita so I am in
neatest I need a star you know let me
lead to a proper introduction for you
you're the proper introduction for me I
need a star is a youtuber sensational
personality lovely to look at but also
funny to listen to at the same time
ladies and gentlemen Anita stars the
evolution of utopia
she is the rising star of what we now
know as stars in this internet consumer
world that we live in introduced to Greg
Alba through Tyrone Magnus they will
make an excellent complete video in the
form of a reaction the most talented
kind of videos there are what are we
doing here I'm doubting death a lot of
weird no I haven't felt it neat at all
what Rocco Rocco videos or look iraq
iraq iraq iraq iraq is is they do like
sketches baby sketches of meetup
sketches they're these guys from
australia new zealand always forget
people always tell me I actually met
them once are these twin brothers that
have the channel ok I have no idea what
this is avenging Deadpool featuring Ryan
Reynolds and Ajax ok those there are
people from the movie Ryan Reynolds
inverter right and any bet maybe the
Green Lantern or do can call me black
for I remember you're all a credibility
humor council represents a technical
ability I want some control of this
ability one of my control planes and the
other one controlled my energies into
the [ __ ] food
the home penny Cooper [ __ ] off Trevor
don't make to be relied on
we hear rugby before a diet now my
name's Craig wait my power is I really
same time every oh stop vertices a B
terms obsessed with a coach I think
she's a little person any was going to
made at home this is that cool and my
favorite superhero and ah he's actually
calling for power for a date for his new
movie indigenous right so why wasn't a
break-in and the resentful and Loan
Corporation clean the heater like I'd
recover an actual junkie I mean it looks
we have some amazing ultimate image and
we're a global media this is legit and
release which is actually
[Music]
has been for everyone this has many
great colleges what what is your fingers
yeah question for the fool
are there any advice for upcoming
superheroes Oh would you be open to the
half-cab rating with enough time
stripping or inserting the ropes like a
Deadpool kima
look at that Sportiva which collect more
oh I don't think that was a Christian a
Deadpool toxic team up with a lunch
people because he's kind of mad and
everything there's a comic book movie in
exert discussion heiresses became you
mean put that tool in a room with with
like oh that's hard to do yeah like
really really well with bug fixes
I noticed kept it and I do living first
sexy legit I shot it down who's that
beautiful you have to finish up a song
[Music]
guy this is d pity you pity you guys
wrote the movie directed patron or what
we did not direct the film we wrote in
there am i talking to me rose oh boy
anything you have to predict Booker you
right in the middle if you don't we're
not
hey you said that superheroes are boring
they shouldn't man [ __ ] [ __ ] how
important she can that is it boy I'm boy
yeah what [ __ ] with you front left
corner and you [ __ ] [ __ ] Superman
[ __ ] you yeah you know what it's not so
much today
going forward here when I would not
really super awkward
[Music]
you politicians and things like that you
know it's amazing that's uh hi hi
om sir nice to meet you yes you look
fragile Hey yes anti-air hahahaha ah
yeah sure so why is your water your
start on him what is your why yeah yeah
yeah yeah
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Oh God there's no disguise Oh
yeah
[Music]
okay yeah it has guys you guys subscribe
to rock or you got the other video
definitely no school man I feel like it
has to be a hybrid of like some of it
might have been actually like okay
welcome Alec state will tell like you
know Ajax active guys name but will fail
ham you know of course of their bit
they're gonna do but I feel like some of
it must have been nothing really that
awkwardness yeah that was just you can't
imitate like you can't gonna get up
yeah all in the room or odor absolutely
and yeah I love sketches especially when
it feels very real at first and then you
turn difficult one yes yes good I liked
it because I feel like that's one of the
cool things about raka raka that they
tend to do also I know there's the first
video you're seeing them yeah but one
thing I think they really do well is
they they do like a combination of what
makes it funny and wacky but let's also
throw some actual legit cool stuff
that's like just make it yeah yeah do
they have that character the archery
boxing guys the internet a nice
reference yeah I look like the crow like
after the crow got hit like a lot or are
you guys truckers believe me train yeah
Galax org
I haven't seen every video there's I
seen the [ __ ] kind of their videos and I
like this character I think it'd be a
funk I mean it's cool that he actually
gave him powers yeah yeah no they really
commit to their stunts you know like
maybe I've seen some bit like they've
gotten seriously injured before because
the main guy played galacto Amon is one
brother who likes which I really okay
okay they run the whole show together
I actually met them at VidCon did you
yeah even more of a reason to go to me
I'm not going in with maybe bad without
doing good gonna slide like a lizard not
going a big puppy no no stop stop Anita
flattered shut up grandma Tommy why do
you make me issues really quick now a
domestic violence humor you know
I felt like a little bit into the
interview with with Edie was when I
started feeling like this has to be fake
yeah yeah yeah that's when I felt it too
I was like okay we didn't play it off
yeah in a plant it seemed like he was
playing along in a way that was like I
can't like it wouldn't gonna be yeah it
would have been more natural I feel but
he wasn't things kind of stiff a little
bit yeah just that kind of smile
[ __ ] [ __ ] you man watching yeah yeah
yeah yeah we were going way better I
know I would have nothin how did you see
my try not to laugh I was so good in
that the writers though felt real I felt
yeah yeah the writers did feel real they
their faces were like who the [ __ ] let
this guy yeah exactly like why are we
doing this you know so yeah that's all
digit they probably made it seem like it
was something that it wasn't and then
they once like started recording to get
the Wreckers were just like really we
agreed to exactly what in the actual and
Ryan Rosen answer to like that made it
seem more than like the way he handled
that yeah she was like that sounds like
a professional handling this kind of
question asked yeah many a time before
so I can I could see that Ryan rose was
ready for it he's like okay one of those
my dress is quite answer around to make
it seem like I'm answering your question
yeah
all right guys will subscribe to Rocco
Rocco please and sort of derive to the
real reject subscribe to a need of stuff
try to I need a star which was a star
here it's the kind of channel she has
that kind of not awesome woody comedy
house perform for you five seconds so
intelligent advances answer better some
relationship oh they're witty possessive